so it's always an imbalance sadly we
like you know it's always more random
than women
but uh you know the man would normally
say oh you women you you need to defend
yourself you know all the things out
there today you need to defend yourself
and when i was at school i know it was a
long time ago they didn't used to pick
on me the bullies
because i'm big
big hands
so they didn't pick on me but when they
did but everybody did pick on me i used
to learn how to fire because i was big
so i could normally win
but what they didn't know is
in the outside world i was as frightened
as anybody had been attacked
you know because i didn't know if i
could defend myself you know i'm good in
a one-to-one fight i didn't know how
good i was at
actually being out there
how many would attack me so so you don't
have to be
any january to be bothered about if you
could handle yourself or not
um so i done aikido because i wanted
somebody's business car business and he
said come to the come to the 12-week
beginners course by kiddo and i've given
you my business for a year
and i needed it because i just started
business so you said i got into okinawa
a really strange way i'm trying to tell
you that my mind was bothered about no
matter how big i am going out there or
going to the town i was still wounded
about being picked on
so i think self-defense is an amazing
thing but you've got to find the right
one for you
the road
and as you said that young lady is that
the best you got easier
[Laughter]
so
a big person
will always be difficult
to throw but there's a place where if i
can create this this back leg here you
see this one i can keep that there
behind him and get sort of angry like a
tree then slowly the tree
will fall down
so you've got to work on angles and this
is where the preciseness comes into play
if i put what i call cocaine
i just hit this rock so i have to put
relaxation
what you can't see
is coke you this as we call it cocaine
it's in my body but it's
so it's a determination that's subtle
if i try to put you in all things
then i'm going to match
a big person with a bigger person
there's no way to win but if i'm
you subtle
it's a complete difference that's why
i'm talking about centimeters you don't
need to worry about that today okay
let's try this thing